I'm a virgin I'm a virgin I'm a virgin
only one is telling the
truth and we're here to find the real
virgin let's get into it for this first
round give us a little introduction I'm
Brian um I'm a chem major trying to get
into forensic science I like anime video
games cool I'm Caleb and I have
anxiety I chose to say I have anxiety
because I have anxiety and story U my
name is Andre I make music think jcole
and I make content I'm Austin like to
collect moss in my free time and Moss
like like plant yeah like go outside and
touch grass and stuff I don't need to
it's in my room oh I think Moss is
really beautiful when it's in like a
small terrarium or ecosystem it kind of
gives like a like a little mini fairy
tale Vibe I'm TJ I'm a hopefully a
future dentist recent college grad and I
like playing basketball in my free time
I was sussed out about like TJ and Brian
from the start especially TJ because
like he just he looks like he has sex
I'm Caleb uh I'm from Fresno California
and I am a social media manager I'm at
church and I also make music and I'm a
podcast producer as
well I run social media for my church I
was like do you do you run social media
for your church coming into this I had
an idea of who might be a virgin for
whatever reason right you do you you
know I feel like wearing a Naruto shirt
is a little too obvious you know I like
Naruto too but I'm not a virgin I feel
like people that go to cons or like
watch anime like they're freaky they're
freaky let me tell you you're a freak
aren't you no yeah I don't know I think
um uh I probably shouldn't have brought
the Naruto t-shirt I also feel like the
the the social media manager for the
church I feel like for the church it's a
little too I feel like it's too on the
nose this guy is giving us nothing so
I'm automatically super sus about him he
looks like a like a like a cartoon he's
dressed like a cartoon character yeah
kind of like Phineas and fur yeah he
just gave
nothing the first person eliminated
is
TJ I guess that's a compliment cuz
they're like oh there's no way he's a
virgin but also like I feel like I could
have proved myself my virginity better
if I had more time but it is what it is
if you are all claiming to be virgins
what is your reasoning it can be such a
sensitive topic there's so many reasons
and I think it was hard teetering that
line of being you know sensitive and
open-minded but also trying to figure
out the answer I uh I'm a Christian stay
perod before marriage and everything so
I believe in that even before I wasn't a
Christian though like I I just felt God
pulling me like kind of away from that
just to protect me in a way and so
that's kind of like why I've just kind
of like stayed away from it if you can
believe it it's hard to meet people with
similar Hobbies I'm not really great
with going out and meeting new people
and it's tough out there uh I'm a man of
God I grew up Pentecostal but now I'm
more non-denominational uh a lot of my
music is themed in Christian themes it's
I'm not necessarily a Christian rapper
but it kind of weaves in there so I I
want to walk what I preach I'm not
waiting for anything I just have anxiety
that's my issue I have anxiety I'm like
me too bro but what is that mean okay
you've done it when you like you talk to
a girl and you like bring her home and
like you've Kissed a Girl and stuff like
that but I've never gotten to the point
like where I've actually hooked up with
her I literally just Spooner the entire
night that's cute uh oh uh yeah like
girls girls don't generally find me
attractive um I I meet a lot of people
who has some comment with anime but like
we only really just talk about like
anime video games and that's really
about it like doesn't go further than
that with Brian I just sus about him
from the start but like just like from
the answers I was like like you're
trying to be too convincing you know
what I mean okay for virginity like
Define virginity to you like what is I
feel like it's pretty hard to Define I
think typically people think of like
penetrative sex but that's obviously not
always the case I think it's up to the
two people to decide like what that is
yeah if you're straight it's definitely
like pounding the punani but like if
you're not then I mean it's definitely
like intercourse that's why I would like
yeah all right cut the [__] what's
everyone's favorite porn
category I don't have one I I straight
up just don't I don't know so you just
like click on whatever uh if yeah when
if if I do it
yeah my P are going to kill me
but reverse gang
bang so hard that's pretty intense who
doesn't watch porn they thought I was
sus but that's clearly not even sus I
feel like us virgins watch porn I also
don't really like watch uh videos but I
like read uh like haai sh my
guy oh this is so hard I think he's
lying I also think he's lying cuz I
don't know the the reverse gang bang
really did it for me I don't know yeah
but I feel like I feel like if if you're
going to watch something like it felt
like a very honest answer I feel like he
was telling the truth I don't know they
both have nose piercings and that just
screams [__] to me no I that just
screams [__] every like I Christian
musicians have like a no string and like
like I don't catch up with musicians sex
is fun and all but do you know what else
is fun subscribing to the channel for
more videos like this now let's get back
to it okay so the first person
eliminated
is AKA Moss guy Moss guy women love
plants you know so it's like you got
plant ribs you can cultivate some
Gardens you can cultivate a hey there
little mama you like plants so the next
person eliminated is
[Applause]
Caleb I feel like one of them is like
like very obvious do you know what I
mean like when people think like oh this
person might be a virgin mhm you know
what I'm talking about yeah but I feel
like it might not be what we expect and
also you you know youall might be really
good fibers we also have two people that
are talking about religious beliefs and
I know that that's a very big thing so
that's throwing me off too defend your
case we'll start being a virgin yeah
we'll start from you yeah I'm just you
know a virgin um I have not really done
anything because I mostly just focus on
my studies and I feel like my past
experiences kind of change how I came to
be that makes sense yeah I feel like I
don't fit The Stereotype I don't know I
just never really got into it into into
what with women so basically the puns
are going
ezy hands is as far as I've gone in high
school and then after that once I
started getting focused music started
working I guess for me uh I definitely
was doing a lot of stuff in high school
but never went that far and and that
kind of carried into like my adult years
but I just never went that far just cuz
like God was just telling me like no
what were you guys like in like college
your high school like did you have a lot
of friends did you not have friends did
you like partying I was in the marching
manand in high school and like the drum
line like that's like the cool people of
the marching man but still marching man
you know I know I played two sports
soccer and baseball and then out of
school I made music uh at high school I
was like a bit of a loner you know I got
picked on a lot I mostly just stuck to
like academics at the end in college Co
came so I feel like that's also another
reason I don't like go out a lot what's
the worst wor thing that you've ever
lied about one time God on SP uh like I
think uh so I uh I guess I lied to my
parents about a test
score there is no way that that's the
biggest lie you ever told lying about a
chemistry test grade sir I I literally I
literally have no idea thinking okay who
were we voting out I don't know though
cuz it's answers were super genuine you
know what maybe maybe do you yeah yeah
okay yeah definitely him I don't know
this guy could be a big freaking liar
let's just pick Let's just pick which
one scream SPG to you the
most first person
[Music]
eliminated wow I did not expect that he
was just like giggling a lot you know
sometimes when you lie you like giggle a
little bit the next person eliminated
[Music]
is it was such a hard we were sweating
it was such a hard decision that I was
like if the lights turned green Andre
was telling the truth and you guessed
right if the lights turn red Andre was
lying to
you
[Music]
damn I'm not a virgin yeah now we know
I'm telling your
pastor can the real virgin please step
forward and also raise their
hand
no stop
dude's it was gigles first guy I'm a
virgin uh because I've kind of chosen to
take that route um mainly because of my
faith with Christianity you know I
believe I should stay pure until I'm
married and that's kind of why I've I've
taken that path yeah so I'm not a virgin
most of half of my music's about sex
let's go and I am in a form of a poly
relationship so oh super first gang bang
so yeah it's just real life you got to
you got to
flip we were close and we were right
about him being a freak I felt like I
was a great fit for the show because I'm
well aware or I'm confident of how I'm
perceived as and I felt like me being
here is able to like break the
stereotypes in one way or another that
would be great what the heck does a
virgin look like I think that is a thing
it's does you know it it challenged all
of my stereotypes anyone could be a
virgin yeah doesn't really matter what
your background is I have a lot of
friends who are you have the same Faith
as me that are not virgin and that's
okay you know I just I'm I'm still a
friend you know there's there's nothing
bad about that um I'm not a virgin and
uh I still have
anxiety awesome yeah that never went
away that's where we're at an anxious
King hey